comment
j'entends
bien les stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bodega
venez danser
chapeau
ce soir vous choque
ce soir
les amis à la terrasse chez moi
là où elle a commencé à félicien verbe
et toi très bien accepté un j'ai accepté
de venir je savais planté trois fois
cette fois je viens
céline dion et sa mission je ne savais
pas perdre ma démission dans laquelle tu
avais proposé des choses j'ai pas pu
passer perso ça c'est bon là c'est pour
un autre projet perso ça n'a rien à voir
alors cette fois je suis là que tu m'a
planté perso voilà était venu
concessionnels qui produit
pourtant de très gentil donc apparaître
des dix ans quel 10 ans 20 ans du
loft de chrome et de singles ce coup mme
magnien 150 semi officielle mais non 750
officiel officiel elle s'apprêtait à les
compiler tout ça ça monte à 1 million
étaient touchés de sa attend des banques
écrit les paroles oui c'est toi ô
goodman j'aurais voulu à la super
surprise s'est pas non plus des paroles
gold saucer chose fait chauffer la comco
mais nous on chante mais moi j aurais
pas pensé par exemple un ânon banon les
rangs des ports banon n'est pas dans ses
vingt ans de numéro 1 du top 50 cette
année mais c'est quoi la coume cc puis
hop et le com com c'est je voudrais
savoir ce que c'est râpé le concours toi
chansons cultes les concours
est souvent chauvet ballack comme que
matin on s'entend savoir